excusez moi je fais partie des gens
quand même qu'ils sont un peu des
spécialistes du principe un on est peu
nombreux
enfin oui je vous avez travaillé quoi la
santé publique ça fait un petit peu
partie de mon domaine d'activité et
qu'est ce que vous dit la cour
en l'absence de consensus de consensus
scientifique le défaut d'un vaccin et le
lien de causalité entre celui-ci et une
maladie peuvent être prouvées par un
faisceau d'indicés
ce qui n'est pas le cas ce qui n'est pas
le cas on va dire que c'est pas le cas
alors que vous avez trop ce que tout les
agents les mêmes la vaillance danoise
dit qu'il attend de voir les pressions
pour l'instant martin mais bien peu de
chose en pose le problème prévoit que je
venais là dans votre esprit ramener ces
notamment l'arrêt sur le sang contaminé
qu'est ce que vous dit l'arrêt du cousin
auteurs mais me dites pas que ça aucun
rappeur de la salle quel était le
problème dans le sang contaminé
c'est qu'on a voulu attendre de savoir
si réellement le chauffage du sens et
est nécessaire on attendre et bombay
qu'elle a ok d'accord alors qu'elle
appartenait à l'autorité administrative
informée de façon non équivoque de
l'existence d'un risque de contamination
des transfusés et la possibilité d'y
parer par l'utilisation des produits
chauffés qui étaient alors disponibles
sur le marché
d'interdire sans attendre laissez moi
finir d'avoir la certitude que
[Rires]
d'attendre sa écouté que d'interdire ce
sans attendre d'avoir la certitude que
tous les lots de produits dérivés du
sang étaient contaminés jeu cette
carence colomb est de nature à engager
la responsabilité aux là je suis
d'accord sur le fond mais ce qui est
hallucinant c'est que même quand vous
avez raison vous dites n'importe quoi
comme vous n'avez pas de documents sur
le confinement alors vous allez nous
ressortir mon vieux trucs sur le
confinement n'est pas utile
comme vous avez des vieux défoncé et
donc et donc vous prenez le sang
contaminé avec un vague arrêt que vous
avez retrouvé
vous ne pouvez jamais avoir les bons
documents et feront au sujet des
d'accord avec vous mais comme vous dites
n'importe quoi et bien c'est un nom
une autre fois j'ai parlé effectivement
du malade imaginaire devant thomas
diafoirus la fois russe vous dire un
truc qui me vient la ccl un livre de
boris vian j'irai cracher sur vos tombes
ah ouais ouais parce que finalement vous
fait qu'elle ait envie de cracher sur ta
gueule c'est ce qu'il fait là ceux qui
crachent sur les tombes des morts était
dite compte sur plus de vieux os au dos
on a sauvé des dizaines de l'angleterre
grâce au vaccin mais je vous le panneau
avec saint est dangereux c'est pas moi
qui le dis vous être pays qu'ils ont
suspendu passé quand même se dire je
veux bien qu'à un moment donné si vous
voulez on passe son temps à dresser un
fort attrait mais je comprends que vous
allez faire des joutes verbales mais ce
que vous dites c'est très dangereux
parce qu'à des gens qui vont croire les
questions à mes deux parents étaient
gênés car je le faisais des risques il
est beau de parler bien sûr j'ai 100 %
de conscience et la séance des questions
aux millions de britanniques vaccinés
s'ils rien passé 11 millions de prises
de l'année je vous posais une question
je fais rien passé oui et aucun effet
secondaire et même pas 30 3% mais c'est
pas grave
peu importe je vous pose est simple en
fait alors allez-y sera posée lab c'est
ça que dites vous ce soir aux français
vous dites vaccinez vous avec ses astra
zeneca ce vaccin est parfaitement secure
et ne présente aucune espèce de
commencement je les appelle le bénéfice
est ce que ce serait que bénéfique j'ai
bel effet si ça veut dire que le
bénéfice est immensément plus grand que
la rose au céleri ce qui n'est même pas
encore prouvé citerai que deux personnes
une personne de 50 ans serait morte
d'une embolie pulmonaire elle à une
embolie pulmonaire après cette vacciner
on sait même pas si c'est relié à la
vaccination
et on sait qu'en écosse il ya eu des 10
min
vies qui ont été sauvées grâce à l'accès
nation n'a vu la courbe de mortalité
chuté drastiquement
alors faites attention communes et des
jeux des médecins plus de discuter
l'habitude sur les faits du confinement
mais là c'est grave c'est la vaccination
c'est le seul vaccin qu'on annonce pour
l'instant c'est la phrase si vous voulez
moi ce que je considère monsieur
blachier c'est que vous êtes
présomptueux dans cette affaire rien
d'autre et que finalement vous prenez
des vessies pour des lanternes et vous
présenter les hypothèses comme des
certitudes et c'est bien ça qui nous
gonfle mais alors il a vacciné ses
parents c'est son problème
alors mais il faut arrêter cinq minutes
avant de donner si vous voulez on a
trois pays qui ont suspendu le vaccin
parce qu'ils ont considéré que le
principe de précaution
combien de paix qui n'ont pas suspendu
s'il est bien de l'italie l'espagne le
portugal la pologne